(man) the sharks are back
in an all-New season
of "Shark Tank,"
Where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
Last year, we grossed 1.5.
1.5?
Million.
How much again?
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
Everything in my bones is saying
This is a runaway hit.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
You take a big risk
with me dropping out.
Not really.
Have you seen me drop out
in situations like this before?
Are you dropping out?
Kevin brings nothing
to a table.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
The logos are crap,
the whole thing's crap.
Is crap the brand?
It's sink...
we're pre-Revenue,
so we're actually--
Oh, I love that word.
Or swim?
The line has been drawn
in the sand.
What are you gonna do?
Are these your best offers?
♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-Made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
went from working
as a waitress in manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent Real estate empire.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
Who grew his homemade
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu.
Robert herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And mark cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas mavericks.
First into the tank
is Val Brennan,
who feels she has a way
to find love
easier and faster.
♪♪
My name is Val Brennan,
and I'm cofounder
of three day rule.
We're requesting
$200,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
Now, we are changing
the way that Singles
in Big cities meet.
I was a lawyer
working 16 hours a day
on my career, and zero hours
a day on my love life.
I just didn't have time
for mass-Market dating sites,
which are filled
with millions of profiles
that are fake, inactive,
or people who I'd never date.
I also didn't have time
to spend yet another
Friday night at a bar
talking to a guy,
only to realize
that he had a girlfriend.
I knew that I wasn't alone,
and I knew
that busy professionals
deserved
a better experience,
which is why we created
three day rule.
Three day rule is unique from
other mass-Market dating sites,
because everyone must be invited
or must be endorsed to get in.
Think of it
as a private dating club,
with the result being
a quality pool
of extraordinary singles.
Here's how it works--
People request membership.
They go through a competitive
application process.
Once people are accepted,
they take a quiz.
We determine
what their type is.
They receive matches,
and can start communicating--
even with me as the cofounder
who is single.
But they can start communicating
with other singles
and quickly go on dates.
We are ready to compete in this
$3 billion market Opportunity
and help the 96 million singles
in this country alone
find love.
Many questions, Val.
First of all,
do I impute from your name,
the three day rule,
that perhaps
after Three dates...
I might...
(laughs)
What am I--what's the word
I'm looking for?
Love?
Action.
Yeah.
No, no, no.
(laughter)
Guys, guys--
When we read that,
we don't read
"Three day rule."
We read "Three date rule,"
you know?
Oh, three date rule?
No, actually...
Oh...
(laughs)
Is that what you're
implying?
No. Let's clarify
any ambiguity.
So, the three day rule
was this rule in pop culture
that people thought, "I can't
call somebody For three days
because I'll seem
too desperate."
Oh...
and what that results in
is people waiting by the phone,
not going out on dates, and not
really meeting the real--
but you are aware of
the three date rule as well?
We are aware
of that rule, but...
what is that rule?
That's not what we're pushing.
What is the three date rule,
Kevin?
Explain that rule, Kevin.
The three date rule...
(laughing)
is an investment
portfolio strategy.
(laughs)
Third date is when
the bond comes through.
You consummate the deal.
(laughs) Oh, god.
(daymond) So this is for
busy, wealthy people, or...
Well, we look for
a number of criteria.
Our demographic
is the 12 million people
who are making
over $50,000.
They have to make
over $50,000 to get in?
No--I mean, it's definitely
who we're marketing to.
What we're looking for
is people
who are established
in their career,
who have had accomplishments,
not only in
their professional life,
but also in
their personal life,
and who are
relationship-Minded.
The key differentiator
from the other dating sites
is that we actually have
an application process,
or a quiz, before you get
onto the site.
You may find this hard
to believe,
but sometimes guys lie.
I know. (laughs)
It's horrible.
Do you validate
any of that information?
We do validate
the answers,
and we have additional premium
services that we'll offer.
An additional
revenue stream for us
beyond the subscription fee
that we're charging
is actual validation.
So members will actually
have a verified--
So unless I buy extra,
I get the liars,
is what you're saying?
But, Robert, Robert,
what's the criteria for women?
You don't think women lie?
I think women tend to be
more honest in dating--
so you're saying Somebody
puts on fake nails,
fake eyelashes, fake lips,
and fake hair...
(laughing)
They're not lying?
(laughs) Good point.
Good point.
Now, how many members
do you have now?
We have about 10,000 people
that have submitted
applications.
Paid the subscription fee?
No. We're pre-Revenue,
so we're actually--
Oh, I love that word--
"Pre-Revenue."
(laughs) We're actually
in our data build.
What it means is you
have no sales.
We launched
about four weeks ago,
and one of the things
that we wanted to do
was build up
a core base of users.
So at this point,
we decided that we will not
implement a paywall,
as they call it
in the dating industry,
until day Three.
Yeah, but that's
hardly a test.
Everybody jumps in
without paying.
One of the things
that we had
is we an earlier version
of this business,
and what we had was a successful
offline matchmaking business.
You had this business before?
We did.
We had events, and we also
had activities,
and we had matchmaking.
And what happened
to it?
So that business
is still existing.
What's happening
is we're actually
scaling that business
to this online offering.
How much is a subscription?
$100 is the base subscription.
For a 1-year subscription?
No, for one month.
So it would be $100
per month.
$100 a month?
Yes.
But you haven't done that yet.
You haven't proven that yet.
You--
we actually have
in our offline model.
How many members do you have
in that original business?
So for that,
close to 10,000 people.
(Barbara) and what's
your revenue for that business?
From that, it was about
$70,000 from last year.
Are you single?
I'm single, yes.
If you're single,
maybe the product doesn't work.
No, it a-- (laughs)
Aww!
That's not True.
I'm creating-- (laughs)
I'm asking.
Maybe she's too picky,
daymond.
No!
I've been single because
I've been working
16 hours a day,
and I don't have time
to really go out
and meet people,
so I'm building this--
but have you gone
on your own Web site?
I have. Actually, that was
my profile you just saw,
so I'm--
so you haven't met
your Mr. Wonderful yet.
Well, I've put up a profile.
I started communicating.
But my business partner
is an expert matchmaker.
She's been matchmaking
for, uh,
pro--a very long time...
(mark) Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
So she has that knowledge.
So if you got 10,000 people,
how many signed up
for the $100 per year fee?
We charge them $1,000
for 3 dates.
Whoa!
$1,000 for 3 dates?
It's actually--
whoa! Boy, you gotta
fall in love right away.
Or you gotta cash
that check right away.
We did. But, uh...
(Robert) So, Val, how long
did you do that model?
We did that model
for about a year.
And you basically made
70 sales?
Right, but we had events
and activities also
where we collected
a transaction fee
and a ticket price
to attend our event, so...
complicated.
Did you make money
on the events as well?
We did.
Is that a revenue generator?
The online/offline commerce
industry is huge.
It's a $3 trillion industry.
Val, I just don't
understand one thing.
Other sites that we see on Tv--
don't they all do...
(Kevin) they do.
A similar thing?
No.
What--what is
the difference?
The difference is we actually
screen people coming in
to the community.
Those sites
don't screen people?
They don't screen...
okay.
So anybody with
an e-Mail address can log on
to some of those
mass-Market dating sites.
Just pretend you worked
for one of those companies,
and we said, "One of your
competitors, three day rule,
said you don't screen at all,"
what would they say?
They probably would agree.
Those--
No.
Those companies
are about volume.
No, I don't think so.
Val, all I care about
is money, okay?
So--and you're gonna have
to explain to me...
yes.
How you make money
at some point today.
Absolutely.
So I'll take you down
the path to revenue.
Members will pay
$100 per month.
They're able to buy
subscriptions
in one-Month, 3-Month,
and 6-Month increments.
We estimate
people will stay on
Probably between
three and six months.
We will make anywhere between
$300 and $600 per customer.
So, if you have
200,000 members,
and you go across
20 Major metropolitan cities,
by year 3, you have
a $20 million business.
But you have
no anecdotal evidence
that that's going to be
your metric.
You know, Val,
you have the perfect answers,
but they're all based
on theory.
Um, I'm looking for
a reason to say yes.
Because if there is
a way to differentiate
and it's real,
you got a home run.
I agree,
and I think we do.
But you haven't proven that.
One last chance.
Okay.
And don't tell me
you have a questionnaire...
okay.
And you have algorithms.
Tell me, what is it?
♪♪
One last chance.
Okay.
And don't tell me
you have a questionnaire
and you have algorithms.
Tell me, what is it?
Our major selling point,
our value proposition
is that everyone
must be endorsed,
so there is social context
around every member.
You know that
that person has gone through
an application process.
They've been approved.
There's an implicit trust
that whoever you're meeting
is someone who's been vetted,
so people don't feel like
they're putting themselves
out there on a dating site
Where everyone can see
their love life.
I just don't think
that's strong enough.
I think that every matchmaker,
they would tell you
the exact same thing.
That's just not enough
of a differentiation,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
I don't think three day rule's
ever going to dominate
the dating business online.
That's already done.
The guys that have
established scale There
now can squeeze you like
a teenage pimple if they want.
(laughs)
They can do all kinds
of things to you
that are gonna hurt
if you start to Garner share.
And maybe they'll buy you,
maybe they'll crush you.
I don't know. But for me,
that's too big a risk.
So for that reason, I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
You're asking $200,000
for 10%.
You do understand you're
valuing this at $2 million?
Yes.
You're not in love
with the valuation?
No, I don't think so.
I'll tell you a little bit
about the valuation.
We already have investors
already committed
and money in the bank
at a $4 million valuation.
And that's--
how much have you
raised there?
We've raised
a $150,000 stake.
At a $4 million valuation?
Yes, that's right,
but we realize
the value that you bring
to the table.
So, Val, you know the saying
"Never trust a skinny chef,"
right?
Well, never invest
in a single matchmaker.
I'm out.
(Robert) So, Val... (sighs)
It's been
an interesting journey.
Okay.
You're very pleasant.
I feel like we're on
a date right now. (laughs)
Oh.
I'm not clear,
and I keep coming back to,
you're just another dating site.
No, we're different.
We are different from
the mass-Market dating sites.
But I don't think
you explained that.
I was looking for you to say,
"Here's all
the other dating sites,
but here's why I'm different."
And for me,
you didn't do that today.
For that reason, I'm out.
You were not convincing here
at all.
In fact, I would say
you were confusing,
and I was listening hard.
And most importantly,
the name is terrible.
Three day rule--
I'm a girl,
and I even interpreted it
the way these guys
interpreted it.
(laughs)
I like that.
Third day, you better put out.
So for those reasons, I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you for your time.
Good luck, Val.
(Robert) You were dead-On
about the name, though.
I love the name!
I think if she could
guarantee the three day rule,
then she'd have something
proprietary, mark.
♪♪
This season, we've seen
millions offered by the sharks.
I'll take $90,000
and add a zero to it.
So now we're at $900,000.
I'll give you $1 million.
You, my friend,
become a millionaire.
Yowza!
Dreams have come True...
take the offer.
Of course. Yes!
Put your game face on!
(Barbara) Good decision.
It's a deal.
And countless lives
have changed.
Since I made a deal with Lori,
we've done $3 million in sales.
She said she was gonna
make me a millionaire,
and here we are.
(pops)
(cheering)
(man)
Since airing on "Shark tank,"
We've sold over $1 million worth
of kisstixx products.
Since partnering with Robert,
we're already over
$1.5 million.
"Shark tank" Changed my life.
We have $300,000 in Sales
in over 300 stores.
(Robert) This is gonna be
a multimillion-Dollar company
very soon.
We have 165 locations,
and we're pointing toward
$20 million in sales.
(man) Since going on
"Shark tank,"
We've done close to $500,000
in just 2 months.
We're on track to hit
$5 million
in this first year.
It sounds corny, but it is
the American dream,
and we honestly feel like
we're living it.
(man) We've been so good to our
local economy here in maine,
we've been invited
to the governor's home.
You're creating great jobs
for the people
in the state of maine.
So keep 'em coming.
(chuckles)
Thank you.
(woman) I don't know where I
would be without "Shark tank."
It's more than just a tv show.
It is sincerely something that
has made my dreams come True.
Now it's your turn.
Ba-Bam!
If you think your business
has what it takes
to swim with the sharks,
go to abc.Com
for your chance of a lifetime.
Next up
are Ryan and Daniela Kelly
with an AFTERSCHOOL business
inspired by Ryan's best friend.
(laughs)
♪♪
A dog and a kid.
Hi. I'm Ryan, and I'm 11.
(laughs)
And I'm his mom Daniela.
And this is Barkley,
my best friend
who inspired me
to start my company,
Ryan's barkery.
We are asking
for an investment
of $25,000 in exchange
for 25% of Ryan's business.
Ryan's barkery bakes and sells
fresh, all-Natural dog treats--
So fresh,
they should be slapped!
(laughter)
If your family is like mine,
then you consider your pet
to be part of the family
just like Barkley.
After we adopted him,
we went shopping
for dog treats
and found
that they smelled horrible.
They couldn't possibly
taste fresh and be wholesome.
Since Ryan and I share
a passion for baking,
we consulted
with a veterinarian
to find out which ingredients
are good for dogs,
then started experimenting
in the kitchen.
We didn't stop experimenting
until we found the flavors
that Barkley
cannot get enough of.
We made super flavors
like pumpkin apple,
banana oat,
and low-Fat cheddar.
Our treats are baked fresh
with simple ingredients
and no preservatives.
I rode my bike
to my friends' houses
and did taste tests
with their dogs.
(laughing)
Their dogs went crazy
for our treats.
Look how Barkley reacts.
(gasps and whispers) a treat.
Look at that.
(Robert laughs)
I started getting calls
from PET Owners
asking where they could
buy these treats,
and that's how
the barkery was born.
With an investment
from you,
we could develop our Web site
and start fulfilling orders
in a commercial kitchen.
We need your partnership
in order to grow,
because I can't do this alone...
(Barbara laughs)
And keep up with my homework.
(laughter)
Thank you for your time.
We brought some treats
for you to see, smell,
and even taste if you'd like.
(gasps)
They're human-Grade?
They are.
Thank you, Ryan.
(Barbara) Wow, great job.
(Kevin) Thank you, Ryan.
They're so cute!
Thank you.
(Robert) Barbara.
Thanks, Ryan.
I've never eaten
a dog biscuit.
Mmm.
Now, Ryan, where you
making these today?
In our kitchen at home.
When do you do it, after you
finish your homework at night?
On weekends?
No.
Early before school,
like at 5:00.
5:00 in the morning
you get up to bake these?
Yeah. Mm-hmm.
Good for you, Ryan.
(Barbara) Wow.
You have any siblings
that help you out?
Uh, yeah,
my older brother Nick.
And is he getting up
at 5:00 with you?
Um, no, be--
sometimes when I--
like lacrosse practice,
and there's an adoption event,
I'll let him go,
and then he can keep
some of the money that he makes.
Your older brother's
working for you?
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Have you sold any of these?
We've sold
about 200 bags of them.
What do you sell--What do you
sell the bags for, Ryan?
$4 a bag,
with 8 treats in each.
And what does it cost you
to make one of those bags?
36 cents each bag.
Ryan, have you made any
attempts to grow the business,
to grow--To sell more bags?
Um, we've tried to sell
at the supermarket...
uh-huh.
But... I don't think
it worked out so well.
What happened?
They were very receptive
to having them.
We quickly found out
that it was better to take out
any middle man, to get
the product directly to the dog.
Ryan, are you selling them
any other way?
Are you selling them
through the community?
Like, we'll bring them
to lacrosse Practice
and s--Um, give out
little samples,
because there's a lot
of dogs there.
And a lot of people
bought them there
and just kept on repeating.
But did they ever buy them
again without you there?
Yeah.
Yes.
At the lacrosse game?
Because the labels have
our phone number on it, so...
Ryan, how much money did you
put into the business,
and Where'd you get
the money from?
(laughs)
From my best investor,
of course--my mom.
(Barbara) How much?
What did mom invest?
How much do you
owe me, Ryan?
$200.
(laughs)
Yeah, have you guys
made a profit?
Yeah.
Why haven't you
paid your mom back?
Because we just
keep on baking them,
and at some
of the adoption events,
I give her a lot of the money
to help pay her back.
(laughs)
Hey, Ryan, where do you
see the business going?
I see, like, stores, um,
with my treats in them,
and the Web site...
Mm-hmm.
Where people could, um,
develop orders,
and then we fulfill them.
Ryan, you know what
Mr. Cuban's gonna say to you?
If you're a real businessman,
you have to quit school
right now...
(laughter)
And do this full-Time.
No, you know what I would
tell you, Ryan?
I'm gonna tell you exactly.
My first business
I started when I was
12 years old.
And the reason I started
my business was because
I wanted a new pair
of basketball shoes.
And I went door to door
to door selling garbage bags.
My garbage bag route
is not all that much different
than what you're doing
with your treats.
But $25,000 is a lot
of money,
and with all that money
comes a lot of responsibility,
and I think it would be
very, very difficult
for you, while you're
still in school
and while you're trying
to balance all these things,
really to put that money
to work, so...
a-as much as I'm--
I'm excited for you,
I'm proud of you, um, I think
you're gonna do amazing things,
but I still have to say
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
Ryan, when I was 11 years old,
I couldn't even dream
of owning my own business.
(Ryan chuckles)
the reason I started my business
is somebody
much later on in life fired me.
But to be 11 years old
and actually go out there
and dream about that--
That's fantastic.
Look, this is not the business
that I want to invest
with you in today,
but I think you'll be back.
And for that business,
hopefully I'll be here,
and we can talk then.
But for this today, I'm out.
Thank you.
Ryan, so where I grew up,
it was, uh...
people all wanted to be rappers
and Gangsters and...
when I told my buddies
that I was going to be
a fashion designer,
they laughed at me.
But I didn't care.
How do your friends
feel about this?
I think they're jealous
now that I'm here.
(laughter)
They are.
Yeah, Ryan!
(Robert) No kidding.
Way to take it to 'em.
Ryan, very few 11-year-Olds
get on "Shark tank."
You're a very lucky guy.
Mm-hmm.
Here you are. It's not
a business yet. It's a Hobby.
Nothing wrong with that.
A Hobby you make money at
is a good thing.
But if you really want
to turn this into a business,
you got a long road ahead.
Yeah.
Good luck to you. I'm out.
Thank you.
I'd love to make you
a full price offer
for exactly what you're asking--
$25,000 for 25%,
because I think this has
the potential to be
a very big business quickly.
(Robert) Wow!
(daymond) Ryan,
I want you to--
And I think Barbara's making
you a very generous offer,
but I--
but what?
I want you to really think
about what cuban said, though.
You're gonna have to sell almost
$150,000 worth of cookies
to pay her back.
Guess what.
You don't have to pay me back
until your 13th birthday.
Bar--Barbara, all I want to--
and all you have to do
is pay me back
$5,000 a year.
By your 13th birthday,
that's gonna be nothing.
Ryan, do you really want Barbara
at your 13th birthday party?
(laughs)
(Barbara) I'm not coming
to your party.
I think Barbara's being
very generous.
I just want you to understand...
the responsibilities.
The responsibility.
I think she is a great partner,
but sometimes money just creates
a bigger problem.
I think you're gonna be
really good without us.
So I'm out.
Ry-Ryan, don't listen.
Don't listen to them.
(Kevin) Listen, don't listen
to any of this.
(mark) No, all I'm saying--
Buy a leather jacket,
take the money, buy a car.
(Robert) Ryan, you--
(laughter)
Gotta say yes or no, guys.
You want it? Yes or no?
Is there anything
to think about?
(laughter)
We have a deal.
Aah!
Yeah, there you go!
All right.
Ya-Ha!
I wish I could adopt you!
Car and college!
Car and College!
Look at this little guy.
Let me lift him up.
(Robert speaks indistinctly)
Whoa! Good job!
Nice job.
Thank you.
Never heard a better pitch.
Congratulations, Ryan.
What a cutie.
(Robert) way to go, Ryan.
Yeah!
I am so proud of you.
Why didn't you guys bid on that?
Barbara has
a great track record...
okay.
With foodie-Type
products.
Yes.
A compliment.
At last, a compliment.
I have a business. This is
gonna be something amazing.
I can't wait to see it
in every dog store there is.
♪♪
I'm Corey ward.
And I'm trew Quackenbush.
We're from cincinnati, ohio.
And we are Tom + Chee.
(sizzling)
Tom + Chee is a grilled cheese
and tomato soup shop
for the kid at heart.
And a beef cheddar
and a grilled cheese donut
going to "C."
I think people Love
grilled Cheese
'cause it is
a classic comfort food.
It's something that everybody
had growing up.
Sandwiches with Melted cheese
on it--
it doesn't really get
much better than that.
What sets Tom + Chee apart
would be our creativity,
the use of many different
ingredients, combinations.
We're always offering
something
that's fun and unique.
One more basket
for a donut, please.
I got a bananarama
coming over.
Tom + Chee is
a family business.
Corey and I
and our wives,
we all emptied
our bank accounts,
we all quit our jobs
to start our cheesy empire.
Our restaurants have been
very busy.
So busy, in fact,
that sometimes it feels
we can't keep up
with demand.
We're ready to go in
and see these sharks.
We need this investment
because the PUBLIC demands
Tom + Chee, and we need
to keep up with them.
♪♪
Good afternoon, sharks.
My name is Corey ward.
And I'm trew Quackenbush.
Our company is Tom + Chee.
We're seeking $600,000
in exchange
for 10% of our company.
(sharks laugh)
$600,000 may seem
like a lot
for an empire built
on cheesy goodness,
but I assure you, once you
taste what trew's cooking...
(sizzling)
You'll be a believer.
Corey and his wife came over
for a cookout at my house,
and he said, "do you want
to open up a grilled cheese
and tomato soup Shop?"
Thankfully,
trew said Yes,
so in the winter of 2009,
we emptied our bank accounts,
we bought a tent
and a griddle,
and set up on
Cincinnati's Fountain square
next to an ice skating rink.
The response was incredible.
What started out as curiosity
quickly turned to excitement,
as word of mouth spread.
And 364 days
after we set up our tent,
we opened our first shop,
and it wasn't long before
we had lines out the door.
Then we got an offer
from a local mall.
They liked our concept so much,
they basically handed us
our second restaurant.
This year, Tom + Chee sold
our very first franchise,
in louisville, kentucky.
With your help, we want to
expand our franchising efforts
and really build
something special.
We now have over 70 employees,
and we're growing.
We are proof the American dream
is still alive,
and we know that with your help,
we will be the next big thing.
I've created our world-Famous
grilled cheese donut
for you to try,
and whoever makes this deal
not only is getting
a good opportunity,
but we're gonna name
a sandwich after you.
Let's feed some to Barbara
and see if she lives.
(laughter)
This is a donut?
It is a glazed--
Yeast-Glazed donut.
Yeah.
(Robert) So I'm eating
a donut that's been Fried?
It's not been Fried,
it's been grilled.
Grilled.
Mmm!
Oh!
I got to admit,
it tastes great.
Is this your only product?
I mean, you mentioned
some of these here,
and I'm guessing there's
tomato soup?
Correct.
Yes.
And you sell traditional
Grilled cheeses as well?
We have over 20 sandwiches
on the menu.
Can we see your menus?
Of course.
Okay, so give us
the breakdown,
because as interesting
as it sounds
to talk about
a grilled cheese and donut,
that doesn't mean that's
what everybody is buying.
Well, our most popular sandwich
is the barbecue Bacon,
where we take
barbecue potato chips,
Bacon, American cheese,
and we put it on white bread.
Does that come
with a defibrillator?
(laughs)
It comes with a lot of "Yum"S,
is what it comes with.
Um, we do pesto and turkey,
we roast our own meats,
create our own
sauces and spreads.
Everything we do
is pretty much vegetarian,
as far as soup Goes,
unless we put meat in the title.
So we definitely are--are
pushing a health-Conscious--
(laughing)
"Health-Conscious"!
health? Health-Conscious?
It's grilled cheese.
(laughs)
So, the sandwiches are
relatively cheap.
The menus
are definitely cheap.
So are you guys perceived
in your marketplace as being
a really inexpensive place
to go get lunch?
I'm gonna re-Articulate
his question.
The menu looks like crap.
The logos are crap,
the whole thing's crap.
Is crap the brand?
It's gourmet grilled cheese
that--
That's given out
at a reasonable price.
In this economy,
everybody needs something
that they can take
a family of five out to,
and we can do that
at Tom + Chee.
You can come in
And you can sit down with--
With all your little kids,
and everybody can have
a great meal
and walk away happy.
You have 70 employees.
What are your sales?
Our--Our two corporate stores,
um, have grossed--
last year, we grossed 1.5.
1.5?
Million.
How much again?
You sold $1.5 million
of this stuff?
In the last 12 months.
Very impressive.
We've actually done
$1,400 in an hour.
They will wait
an hour and a half
just to get up to order.
If I drove by your shop,
I'd see people lined up
out the door?
Yes.
Out the door.
Tell me what
the franchise fees are.
Okay, So, uh, to get in,
it's, um, $35,000.
And then, like, 7.5%
comes back to us.
And our franchisee,
he had to spend about
$250,000 to get
his first store open.
How's his monthly sales doing?
Great.
He did $100,000 last month.
Wow.
You know what I love
about your business?
You have
the most important ingredient--
the magic
of any great business--
You've got a line out front.
Yeah.
And I'm going to give you
an offer.
I'm gonna give you...
half of the $600,000
for 30% of the business
if you can get another shark
in on the deal.
I'm sitting here
and I'm thinking to myself,
what's the odds that these
two guys are gonna win?
And everything in my bones
is saying This is a runaway hit.
This is a Winner.
I want to let you guys
get a little more focused here.
Okay.
My portfolio kinda goes
the opposite way.
I-I really believe
in healthy products,
so this just wouldn't be
for me. I'm out.
Okay.
You know, I'm sitting
on the fence here,
looking at this saying,
these guys have come up
with something so outrageous
that it worked.
I would have never thought
this would have Worked, ever.
And it has. All right,
I'll tell you what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna throw 100 grand in
just to be a piece
of this really crazy idea.
All right, I'm in on that.
How much you in, Robert?
You have $100,000 or $200,000
available.
I'm in for $100,000.
Barbara, Robert, and Kevin
have made an offer, but trew
and Corey need another $100,000
from the last remaining shark
to reach the $600,000
they have asked for.
What are you thinking,
mark?
You know you have
the resources to help us grow.
We've done our research.
I'm not gonna do $100,000.
It's just not worth
the time and aggravation.
But...
what I will do is
I'll go in with Barbara.
I'll match
Barbara's $300,000.
So each of us will put in
$300k for a total of $600k,
for a total of 30% equity,
but I don't want
all the sharks in.
That's just too much work,
too much Hassle,
too much paperwork.
And in addition,
I want the rights
to the state of texas,
just in case it takes off.
We actually have a--
a very interested person
for Dallas already.
Well, then
we'll carve out Dallas,
and if they don't close,
then that'll revert
back to me.
And may I say
I want new York?
Because I'm gonna be jealous
of him carving that out.
(laughs)
I'm--I'm sorry, guys.
I'm not in love with it enough
to compete and start
to bid this thing up.
I just can't get there.
I'm out.
I'll clear the field.
You got Barbara, you got mark.
$300,000 each for 30%.
What do you say?
I'd say we take the Deal.
Yeah.
Yes, sir!
Thank you, mark.
This is gonna be awesome.
You gu--You were the two
that we were talking about
the whole time.
It's not easy being
cheesy, right?
You know it.
(laughter)
Good for you. Good for you.
Thank you, guys, so much.
You gotta shave a little,
you know?
(laughs)
Would have never seen that
coming.
Not in a million years.
Awesome.
(laughs)
I've already got
all the people in place.
I've got a buyer. I-I can
take it to wisconsin cheese.
Good. You do all the work,
I'll collect the profit.
It's a deal?
No.
(laughs)
That's not a bad deal
for $600,000.
Who's ready to make
some cheddar? (laughs)
(laughs)
♪♪
Next up is Ryan Frankel
and kunal sarda
with a business to help
global communication.
♪♪
Me llamo Ryan Frankel.
Did you get what he said?
He said,
"My name is Ryan Frankel."
(laughs)
Me llamo kunal sarda.
Nosotros somos Los Fundadores
de verbalizeit.
Whoa!
He is kunal sarda,
and they are the cofounders
of verbalizeit.
Estamos buscando DOSCIENTOS
CINCUENTA MIL DOLARES
POR QUINCE POR CIENTO
DE nuestro compañia.
They are seeking $250,000
for 15% of their company.
In case you haven't
figured it out,
Erica is a translator,
and her job is to help
people from around the world
talk to each other.
Verbalizeit allows you
to put Erica
in your back pocket.
Here's how it works.
With verbalizeit,
you simply register
at the verbalizeit Web site,
or download the app.
Within 15 seconds, you press
a button on your phone.
You're instantly connected
to one of our live translators
around the world.
You tell that translator
what you need,
place the phone on speaker.
Our translators communicate
on your behalf.
Every year, millions
of international travelers
run into situations where
they cannot communicate
because of
the language Barrier.
We want to work with you
to put verbalizeit
in the hands of individuals
and businesses around the world.
So who's ready to make a deal?
Thank you, Erica.
What's your background?
Where did you come from?
Uh, kunal and I met
in business school.
What business school
did you meet in?
At Wharton.
Wow.
(daymond) hmm.
Ryan, walk me through
how it works.
I download the app.
Do I call
international 1-800 numbers?
Yes.
Correct.
Your call is Routed directly
from our virtual call center
to one of our thousands
of translators
around the world.
So you're sourcing people
that have capacity
at that moment,
anywhere in the world--
if I'm in egypt, if I'm
in russia, I'm in cyprus,
I need greek--You have
enough people now sourced
to actually translate for me?
That's what's really
interesting, Mr. Wonderful.
(sharks laugh)
We have created
this global community
of multilingual individuals
who are monetizing on
their spare time during the day.
This is very interesting,
but I'm trying to figure out
the business model,
because the key to this is,
every single time I call,
the guy's gotta be there
translating for me
30 seconds later.
Absolutely.
We have 2,000 translators
already around the world,
and we're live
in Five languages,
and we can connect your call
within 15 seconds
of you dialing
into the system.
I'm trying to figure out
how you can get
somebody that quickly
in a language,
24 hours a day, 7 days a week.
It's a great question, sir.
What we've created here
is a powerful community
of people around the world
who speak a second language
and want to be able to make
money during their spare time.
So by virtue of having such
a large population of people
who want to make money,
your call will automatically
always be answered.
So, Ryan, how do you pay them?
So, first of all,
let's go to the traveler.
Kevin's traveling.
Does he pay you
to download the app?
The app is free, so anyone
who goes to the App store
can download it for free
and try it for free,
one free call.
And then afterwards,
our customers pay anywhere
from 50 cents to $1 per minute,
depending on how many minutes
they buy.
And then how do you pay
the translators?
Translators make anywhere
between $7 and $15 an hour
based on every minute
that they translate.
What percentage
of the 50 cents
you're collecting a minute
is that?
Uh, we have a 70% margin.
And what are your sales
to date?
In the last 2 weeks,
we have had $10,000 in sales.
How long has it been
on the market?
Verbalizeit has been live
as of one month.
How do you filter
these people?
How do you get these, uh,
translators, and how do you
trust that they're gonna
translate Correctly?
Uh, the first and foremost,
we found 50 TRANSLATORS
by going out and talking
to language learning centers,
and we said, "Okay, would you
like to join our community?"
and then we got tremendous
word-of-Mouth referrals.
Do you have a ratings system
after the Call is over...
yes, we do.
To rate the translators?
We do. So you build up
a reputation
as a higher-Quality translator,
you make more money.
Wow.
Our top translator made
$550
in the last 2 days.
There are so many
translation apps out there.
Why is this specifically
different from everything else?
Well, on the one hand, you have
machine-Based technology,
which just doesn't work.
And I'm gonna disagree
with you there significantly.
Machine language translation
does work,
particularly
in a business environment.
So you have to go out
and find translators
that understand business.
Because if we are doing a deal,
and someone said
they've got
a subordinated note
that has a buyout at 13%,
and we're gonna do
a Cram--
whatever it may be,
typical Translator's
not gonna understand that.
Our community ranges
from people
who have just graduated
high school
to people who have their phds
and their business degrees.
But you lose
your instantaneous aspect of it
because that person
has got to be available.
'cause it's not like
there's an unlimited number
of those people
willing to work cheap.
What does your business
look like
in terms of the languages?
So we are live
in Five languages, as I said.
Which five?
Hindi, mandarin,
spanish,
portuguese, and French.
Why not croatian?
(sharks laugh)
We don't have a translator yet.
How about joining us?
I got some time.
We've only been live
for a month,
and we're very excited with
some of the large partnerships
that we're working on.
We just launched a pilot
with Skype,
which means that any one
of the 31 million Skype users
can add a verbalizeit translator
into any conversation.
You've made that deal
with skype?
We have. We--
wow. Hang--Whoa.
Tell us how that deal works.
Wow.
So we reached out to skype,
given the--
the fact that
they're a fantastic company.
We are now the featured app
in the skype app directory.
Is it an exclusive deal?
Can someone else
in your space come in
and also offer
the same thing to skype?
Well, since we don't have
an exclusivity agreement,
someone could technically
come in.
I see.
There aren't a lot
of companies out there
doing what we're doing,
and we do have
a word-of-Mouth agreement that
that won't be the case.
I happen to think
that skype piece
is the sex appeal
in the whole deal.
Creates a lot of confidence.
I really thought that was
a real deal,
like you cornered
the skype space.
So I'm out. 'cause... too shaky
for me. I'm too scared.
So, guys, my other fellow sharks
are asking a lot of questions,
because there's clearly gonna be
some blood in the water.
This is really
in their tech space.
But I'm gonna watch them fight,
and this is really
gonna be good.
I'm out.
Thank you.
See, Ryan, mark loves
to hear himself talk so much
that when he's quiet,
I know there's something
going on.
Guys, I'm--I'm gonna make
this easy for you.
I've made several investments
in language.
One of the challenges is,
no solution has everything.
Human translators
sometimes don't fit
for very verticalized
applications,
because you can't hit 'em all
fast enough
or find the right people.
Machine language--
vice versa.
So when you go
into big commercial accounts,
it'd be a huge bonus
to have both.
So, what I'm willing to do,
without hearing
any of these guys,
because that's just
a waste of time...
is $250,000 for 25%,
yes or no?
♪♪
Why don't you go ahead
and step in the hall
and talk about it, okay?
Because I don't want it
to be polluted
by these guys,
'cause it just drags things on.
Do you want to hear
any other offers?
We--we want to hear
other offers, correct.
(Kevin) Good.
Then you take--You take
a big risk with me dropping out.
Not really.
Have you seen me drop out
in situations like this before?
Are you dropping out?
♪♪
Mark has made an offer
of $250,000
for 25% of the company,
but Kevin and Robert are both
circling around the bait.
Just to keep it interesting,
I'll give you $250,000 for 20%.
I'll do $250,000 for 25%.
I think you guys
are smart guys.
I think you'll pick
the right partner.
♪♪
Are these your best offers?
Can we have a moment
to talk about it?
(mark and daymond) Sure.
Absolutely.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you.
It's a fascinating model.
He's a cool character.
(kunal) So what do you think?
Some good offers
on the table.
It's a little bit low--
Lower than what we wanted.
I wouldn't mind going
with, um,
mark and Robert if we can
bring them down to 20%.
What do you think?
Mr. Wonderful has
a lot of experience.
He does have
Do you want him
as an investor?
(Robert) I gotta tell you,
I think we could have got
a better deal if we, uh,
went in on this together.
Who do you think's
gonna get it?
I don't know.
This is a tough one.
♪♪
(daymond) All right, guys,
you've had a discussion.
What have you decided?
Well, we love
all three of you.
You have all made
amazing offers.
But the one thing we've
learned in Business school
is that it's not just about
creating value,
it's also about
capturing value.
So we'd like to understand
a little bit better
whether or not mark and Robert
Can improve their offers
to beat
Mr. Wonderful's offer.
I'll add one thing.
I have somebody
who works for me--
All she does is
machine language translation.
If you don't think 5% is worth
just an introduction
to one of the most advanced
Machine language translation,
um, software systems
and servers in the business...
(clicks tongue)
That's up to you.
♪♪
You have to believe
that machine language deficits
give you incremental business,
and it may or it may not.
Your business model
isn't actually tied to that.
You need the flexibility
to expand the opportunity
and do a little more research
on what the best path is,
and here's what I know--
You want to give up
as little equity as you can
right now,
because if it works,
every single point
is gonna be worth a fortune.
You know what, guys?
That's a whole shakespeare
"Much ado about nothing."
That whole sentence.
I mean, I've been selling
into the call center Environment
When Kevin still had hair.
I actually had
a call center Business.
That's the difference.
He's just a sales rep.
I ran a business.
Oh, my--my friend, I'm much
more than a sales rep.
At the end of the day,
you've got to make a decision
about how much equity do you
want to part with now?
Kevin brings nothing
to a table.
You know, with all due respect,
I think mark is in that business
like I'm in that business.
No, they're not
in your business.
I'm gonna stick
to my $250,000.
They're not doing
what you're doing.
No, I-I really am
in their business.
You're in
machine language translation.
That's not the same thing.
I'm calling
on the same customers,
which is all the more reason.
That's not--
That's also not True.
Yes, it is True.
(daymond) All right, guys.
The line has been drawn
in the sand.
These are hard offers
by the sharks.
What are you gonna do?
Estamos pensando. Okay?
(lowered voice)
What would you like to do?
(whispers indistinctly)
Mr. Wonderful,
you have a deal.
Oh!
Whoa.
Whoa!
(Barbara) Surprise.
Looking forward to working
with you guys.
Likewise.
Wow.
(Kevin) Very interesting.
Thanks a lot.
(speaking indistinctly)
Take care. All right.
Congratulations.
♪♪
Wow, I'm surprised.
Every dog has his day.
(Barbara) Well, well.
I love that deal.
You know what
I just realized?
Those guys spoke
the language of money,
not the language of building
something of value.
You know what the good news is?
I'll end up competing with them.
Bring it on.
In the end,
it wasn't about the 5%,
but Mr. Wonderful just showed
that he really understands
what our business
is about.
We're really excited
to be working with him.